yes james harden is taking a 15 million
pay cut next season but don't you start
thinking he'll be short of cash because
james harden is making a lot of money
outside of basketball let's unpack his
earnings back in 2015 hardin left nike
and signed a 13-year 200 million dollar
deal with their rival adidas breaking
that down alone it's 15 million dollars
a year 1.3 million a month and 42 000 a
day as for his other endorsement harden
is racking in millions a year from these
companies as well but now it's time to
get into his investments he invested in
body armor back in 2014 at the time it
was only valued at 60 million but then
in 2021 coca-cola bought it in an 8
billion deal that's roughly a 13 000
gain for hardin in 2019 hardin bought a
15 million dollar stake in the houston
dynamo and the houston dash another
notable investment of his was with the
art of sport body care brand which was
co-founded by kobe bryant hardin
released his first signature fragrance
with the company called defy whose
portfolio do you want to see next